pour évoquer le calysto rebelles nous
sommes avec jonas moody journaliste
bonsoir jeunesse maudit merci d'être
avec nous alors comment selon vous
expliquer ce faible bilan dont se targue
l'islande pour répéter s'il vous plaît
comment expliquer ce faible bilan
je ne suis pas sûr de pouvoir
l'expliquer mais je pense qu'il est
beaucoup de tests grâce au secteur privé
tout comme secteur public et il ya
également un traçage des contacts mise
en place très rapidement donc avec ses
connaissances dans pu l'être les
personnes en quarantaine rapidement et
les séparer de la population lorsqu'il
était contaminée donc cela a permis de
maintenir de gérer la pandémie
effectivement un dépistage massif à
l'instar d'ailleurs des pays qui ont de
faibles bilans justement la corée du sud
taïwan ou bien même plus proche de chez
nous l'allemagne ça veut dire que
l'islande était préparé à ce type
d'épidémie
je ne sais pas si nous étions mieux
préparés mais en tout cas la réaction a
été rapide et l'équipe était menée par
des scientifiques les milieux politiques
qui n'étaient pas ce premier plan cela
nous a sans doute aidé alors ce qui est
intéressant à distance et
qu'effectivement il ya eu ce dépistage
massif mélisande contrairement à la
plupart des autres pays n'a pas imposé
de confinement à sa population
juste l'observation des gestes barrières
quel a été le comportement justement de
la population à ce niveau là très
respectueuse a sans doute les island et
plus sont pas vraiment très partisan des
règles donc je ne sais pas si les
personnes suivait de très près les
consignes à mais y ait d'autres mesures
telles que justement les tests à grande
échelle et le traçage des contacts j'ai
en tant qu'étranger vivant en islande
j'étais assez inquiet mais en tout cas
la situation marche bien car le taux de
contamination a baissé les décès il y en
a très peu
mais c'est assez difficile pour les gens
et ils ont bien envie et d'ignorer ces
consignes
je vis à reykjavik
je marche pas mal dans la rue et je n'ai
pas vu beaucoup de gens observer la
règle par exemple des deux mètres très
peu de personnes essayent de garder
leurs distances
les gens se rendent au restaurant
parfois les restaurants met en place dès
distanciation mais pas tout le temps il
ya beaucoup de laxisme et cela est
préoccupant mais avec que l'ombre eux
siba je ne sais pas si c'est nécessaire
de 5 électivement vous nous faites un
petit peu rond il pas trop en gros vous
êtes en train de dire que pas grand
monde ne répète quoi que ce soit en
islande en terme de deux voilà deux
gestes barrières n'y a pas de
confinement mais que à la faveur des
tests massive et d'un traçage les choses
fonctionnent plutôt bien
soit en tout cas on retiendra ces
informations
on y réfléchira il ya également un
retour dans les lycées et les
universités qui est de mise en ce moment
ça aussi vous faites des choses à l
inverse fin de la france où les lycéens
ne sont pas prêts de retrouver les bancs
de leurs établissements
comment a été accueillie cette mesure en
i stand effectivement les plus grands
qui retournent à l'école trop la
réouverture des écoles n'est pas très
bien comprise
les universités ne rouvre pas vraiment
la plupart des personnes finissent leur
semestre à distance et c'est vrai
également pour la plupart des lycées
merci merci je n'applaudis d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur arte france pour
nous exposer la situation islandais
votent